modern women waste their best years
what do you think what okay awesome just
pearly mama what do you think about it
do you think do you think modern women
waste their best years straight up yikes
what do you think about it because why
are you wasting your time tramping
around with all these people when you
can pick the one and be with that one
forever and that's the one that goes You
Know You're On The Headstone with and I
just don't understand why I literally
don't understand I think it's everyone's
dream is to find the one but at the time
we live it's been difficult yeah like
and the first problem in the
relationship is so easy to you to be
replaced the guys just go on the day
trip and find 10 000 dates next day so I
think it's very difficult to keep
together in a relationship because now
the people have a feeling that's so easy
to find the day to find someone
so I think like
for this part technology doesn't help
much and I don't I don't disagree I mean
I think that's that is a hundred percent
true
however I also think that you know in a
marriage you know I mean Hannah would
like to think her dad's perfect he's not
I'm not like it's not a perfect marriage
for sure however we have you know a bump
in the road here and there every time
you go through a different relationship
you have another bump in a road except
it's like a mountain and so why not be
in a situation where you are evolving
and growing and evolving and growing
together and I can tell you that our
relationship started out in a really
horrible place and can I share this do
you care what
okay so
um you know first my husband and I were
we met through my brother my sister was
engaged in my husband's brother and they
never married so that's a pretty big
bump and then I get pregnant hit a baby
gave him up for adoption
that's a really big [__] bump talk
about a bump that's like not a bump
that's like Mount Everest
and then we managed to build the company
have a family you know get married have
a family and have him come back into our
lives that's another big bump every one
of those are hard but the only things in
life you're proud of are the things that
were hard so why not be willing to go do
the hard things
because our generation we are not strong
like you are I think like I don't I
don't agree I look at you and I I
literally am sad because I think like I
want that for you I want you to think
differently I want you to think that to
Value yourself and to think like you are
worthy of that and there's not you know
just talk about the men mostly I think
like the guys who are attending the
provider who's going to protect the
house I wish all the men could represent
this kind of security but our generation
I have the feeling
they maybe they've been with less trauma
less things they are not the tough
there's less of them there is less of
them but there's also less competition
for good quality women I mean there's so
you know the just let all the trash hang
out at the gutter and go rise up
no that I agree that I agree I think
like the same ways difficulture find the
man is just go to find the traditional
women can I um so we we've kind of been
talking about
traditional modern I'm just going to do
an experiment three there's three guys
in here right do you want to protect and
provide for your girl yes or no depends
on the girl oh come on
not by yeah yeah if you want to protect
and provide for your girl yeah do you
want to protect and provide yep there's
three right there but it's like
interesting because I'm asking you guys
more traditional questions and the
answers don't line up so like I honestly
think there's more traditional men than
traditional women nowadays I think the
shortage is an RN not theirs I think
there's a lot of men that want to
protect and provide but like who are
they going to protect and provide for
women that don't listen to them why
would you protect them and that's why I
said that doesn't listen and that's why
I said the pins that's that's why like
obviously as a man like you are going to
want to be in that position because if
you are protecting and providing it does
put you in the position of leadership
and Authority in your household like
with your woman but or in your
relationship or whatever but
unfortunately like a lot of us guys
let's say guys of this era we are coming
across a lot of girls that this on know
wifey material this is not bro and it's
not I'm not saying they're bad people
I'm not saying they're horrible people
or they can't change but I'm just saying
like bro like we're meeting a lot of
girls that when you meet them they're
not wifey material bro recreational use
we can be friends that smash or whatever
like that's it like and that's it
and you know there's certain things I've
said like there's things I've we've
we've discussed and I've said things in
a logical from a logical standpoint that
you just like you're just totally
rejecting without any logic base or you
just well this is what I think this is
just my opinion the world doesn't run on
just just it causes your opinion the
world runs on logic and what makes sense
and there's equations to everything like
do you get what I'm saying and if you
just try to live your life of some fairy
tale Disney movie I'm sorry like it
doesn't work it doesn't work it's not
real it's not reality the moms die in
Disney movies huh most of the moms die
in Disney movies think about it Dumbo
wife die or mom died Bambi mom died
Frozen mom died
wears Snow White's mom I don't know
I just want the whole thing tonight
there's not a single mom that's alive in
Disney
Pocahontas but it's like it's like guys
we're told as like a society that we can
just we don't have to listen to men we
can do whatever we want in our younger
years and that at the end of the day
there's going to be a fairy tale waiting
or we're going to be alone and we're
really going to be happy with it and I
just think that's a lie I I I just I
think either you make certain choices
and you don't get the men you want or
you know you you wind up by yourself and
I just genuinely don't believe the women
you're talking about are happy I don't
think they would prefer to be alone
rather than with a family
is very subjective I'll talk about
happiness because like it depends for
women I know a lot of women who after
lost their husbands they never got
married and they are happy
I know people who started dating they
are happy so I think it's very
particular and unique it depends of the
the human being to remember being and
do you think they're happier by
themselves or with their husbands
it depends of the hands but sometimes
they're there better by themselves for
sure it's always going to depends if
each case is very different or the other
some people are happy together some
people are not so it's very like like I
said like on social media we just watch
the top of the iceberg we don't know
what the problems what they're being
through like you can tell about Shakira
now with everything she's going through
she's crying Miley Cyrus everyone has
personal problems and now they they put
on social media but they've just put the
part they want to they not the whole
thing so I think it's very it's changing
the idea of course everyone's would like
to have a family but I also believe that
people now have a different kind of
family a person who is single but got a
dog or a cat is their family I don't
know why Shakira left him not a good
move on her part
yeah she should have stayed Shakira yeah
I mean he was he was yeah okay yeah yeah
I mean look he was cheating sure but I
mean she You could argue she was
cheating by shaking her ass at the Super
Bowl like it's like women always wanna
women always want to say oh it was the
man
but you were you were shaking your butt
at the Super Bowl how that's not loyal
so it's like we always wanted we always
want to blame the men always blaming the
men but it's like he got 10 ass pictures
on Instagram you've been shaking your
butt for all of these men to see and
then he steps out once and he's the bad
guy oh come on what do you think about
what Paul just said
I just think that's much though what's
mad
he knew what she was when he met her
like she'd been doing that and she knew
you know what I mean no but she's been
shaking her ass like that you're right
but she but she knew who but she knew
who she he she knew who she was with
when she met him if you if you're gonna
date the top rich and powerful men in
society right that also are famous which
what percent of famous men are loyal you
know what you're getting yourself into
you're not done she might not have been
able to cook with it anymore you can't
say to someone just stay I don't know
what maybe he could maybe he was sick of
coping with his his wife shaking her
butt on Instagram my whole it could be
my lesson my whole point is like women
always want to point the figure at men
and say oh it's the man it's the man oh
like we always want to look at cheating
with no Nuance like oh he cheated but
what did she do and you also don't know
why he did but she didn't cheat though
but I get what you like
I'm saying I think it's the same problem
guys men never are honest when they want
to break up I think they start to behave
if like
it's like a lot of times like my mom was
saying earlier like people aren't
perfect and so she's gonna say oh he
cheated okay yeah he cheated but I mean
you could argue you're cheating by by
showing your body on Instagram that's
not very loyal to your husband but he
that's that's what it doesn't make sense
to me because if you didn't stop it why
did you why did you go to a girl like
that then like it doesn't make sense to
marry a girl probably because
it doesn't matter right there but they
but the whole point is they probably
match I mean she's putting her butt on
the Instagram he's probably cheating
they probably match as a couple like
that's that's what they're doing so that
my whole point is she wants to go on
social media and play victim and say oh
I did nothing wrong
okay yeah Miracles miracles happen but
it's like am I gonna bet that like I
mean have you seen Hollywood the last 10
years come on come on you know you know
they're all cheating so it's like my
whole my whole point is not that
cheating is okay I'm not saying that
cheating is good my whole point is that
women want to say that they are the
victim when a lot of times they're not
because they're doing the same in a
different way because men and women are
different thank you yeah I think they
the women doesn't have the courage to
end up or break up the relationship Men
start to behave differently and the
point I was going to end up at
communication because people are not
communicating and
I think that's this equation but of
course easy to blame women don't have
the courage to leave no 2023
courage women normally drop a guy do you
know someone who has the currency
we got to Ryan the eating Warrior for
the Super Chat he says for the sound
board with the with the uh you know the
thank you hands yeah I had to shout that
out but when I saw that well big up to
you bro anyway I just wanted to hear
what you said
um I feel like women in these days
normally leave the relationship mentally
way before the relationship has actually
ended like and I don't know about you
guys but I personally feel like as a
known fact because even with some of my
friends people I've known they're just
like over it like they're over it but
they're not kind of looking because
they've yeah they've had their headed
too long on social media and they're
dreaming about some reality that doesn't
exist as many
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible